[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le match franceangleterre de rugby a été
pour l'équipe française et pour les
spectateurs du stable de colombe le
match des illusions perdu le démarrage
des Français maillot foncé était
pourtant très prometteur mais les
avances sont bien
habouff par les
Anglais offens comm C iloup cependant
les
att dans laiss
de pour les
Anglais
magifanais sera qu Mme la plus BA de
tout match
allons mademoiselle voz-vous la face
c'est rugby tout de même rien ne les
arrête au cours de la deè mi-temps au
début du moins on croit qu'il est encore
possible à la France de prendre
l'avantage piqu le centre droit se fait
souffler une balle on se demande encore
comment et c'est le départ de toute la
cavalerie
anglaise ce mouvement illustre la
supériorité des Anglais sur les Français
dans les du
je c'est un véritable déferlement qui
aboutira à l'essai de la victoire dans
cette phase de jeu les Français sont
complètement
affollés on cherche encore une
explication à ce passage à vite de
l'équipe de France qui a définitivement
perdu le tournoi desessin naation cette
année
la visite que le Président de la
République italienne monsieur Antonio
seier a rendu à Paris et qui a conduit
au côté du général de Gaulle sur le
tombeau du soldat inconnu a souligné
l'amitié qui unit traditionnellement la
France et
[Musique]
l'Italie ce voyage aussi le mérite à
l'occasion des entretiens des deux chefs
d'État de préciser la position des deux
partenaires du marché
commun
premier effet de la reprise des
relations entre Paris et Pékin le
premier chargé d'affaires de la Chine
populaire est arrivé à Paris en même
temps que Monsieur chayet chargé
d'affaires françaises arriv à Pékin nul
doute comme l'a dit lui-même monsieur
sunchiwang qu'à la faveur de cette
reprise les relations entre les deux
pays ne connaissent un nouveau
développement Paris du reste s'est déjà
mis à l'heure de la Chine pour son trè
passage dans la capitale française l'opé
de Pékin a apporté sur la scène 5000 ans
d'art de culture et de
civilisation c'est tout à la fois
l'oreille et l'œil que plonge dans la
surprise des tableaux comme l'attaque de
la forteresse prétexte à de
vertigineuses acrobaties sur des
sonorités
[Musique]
étran
un thème folklorique qui met au prise un
vol de Gru et une bande de vaauour c'est
encore l'occasion d'un tourbillon d'une
avalanche de soie et d'étoffes pailleté
[Musique]
d'or
danse acrobatie poésie musique c'est
tout cela à la fois l'Opéra de
Pékin jours après l'assassinat du
président Kennedy assassin présumé Lee
Oswald était dans les locaux de la
police de Dallas et en dépit de son
escorte de policier tué à coup de
revolver sous l'œil des caméras par un
tenancier de boîte de nuit Jack
Ruby la cour criminelle de Dallas a donc
aujourd'hui à juger Ruby mais
pourra-t-elle le faire c'est en effet la
question qui se pose dans ce procès qui
draî laattention générale et autour
duquel des précautions extraordinaires
ont été prises Ruby a pris pour assurer
sa défense l'un des avocats les plus
célèbres et aussi les plus astucieux de
la la côte ouest Melvin Bay qui demande
le transfert de la cause loin de
Dallas le juge Joe Brown a cependant
fait commencer la sélection des jurés
appelés à juger Ruby ils sont 900 et il
en faut 12 on peut donc se demander au
bout de combien de temps Ruby se
trouvera devant ces 12 jurés la défense
et l'accusation en effet font tellement
assaut de défiance que dans la première
semaines deux jurés seulement ont été
acceptés à ce rythme il faudrait 6
semaines pour avoir un jury
et Ruby qu'on amène sous bonne garde de
la prison au tribunal va assister
passivement au curieux début d'un procès
qui contrra sans aucun doute parmi les
procès du
[Musique]
siècle
les derniers becs de gaz de Paris
évoquent aujourd'hui une époque révolue
celle où les braves gazomètres et les
four àqu fournissaient ce que l'on
appelait d'ailleurs le gaz d'éclairage
inventé dès la fin du 18e
[Musique]
siècle déjà il y a 150 ans le gaz avait
commencé à éclairer le trait parisien
passage des Panoramas aujourd'hui le gaz
est devenu gaz de chauffage et ces
dernières années les réseaux gaziers se
sont multiplié à travers la France en
1963 la région parisienne a consommé
plus de 2 milliards de mètres cubes de
gaz demain le premier bateau méthanier
amènera sous forme liquide à -160° le
gaz naturel du Sahara d'importants
travaux sont en cours au port du Havre
pour le recevoir il viendra compléter
dans les grandes centrales gazières le
mélange déjà préparé à partir du gaz de
lac et du gaz tiré du
charbon les besoins au gaz de chauffage
ont transformé de de fon en comble une
industrie vieille d'un siècle et
[Musique]
demi cette saison chez Christian Dior
Marc Bohin a fait surgir d'un coup de
baguette magique le couturier n'est-il
pas un magicien une collection jeune
alerte et plus féminine que jamais pas
de révolution pas d'audace intempestive
mais au contraire une note sage la note
de la femme dans la vie et en effet les
tailleurs de l'après-midi aux vestes
courtes plus courtes sur le devant que
dans le dos tailleurs sportifs parfois
même à veste longue donne une ligne très
proche de la ligne naturelle buste
souple et hanche affiné par l'évasement
de la
jupe les robes de cocktail sont en
général des robes maillot restituant à
la femme sa grâce naturelle et dont la
discrétion et le luxe des détails font
le
[Musique]
raffinement enfin pour les dîners et les
grands soirs les robes ont une nouvelle
longueur elles s'arrêtent au-dessus de
la cheville avec pour couleur Toutes les
teintte que prend le ciel entre le lever
et le coucher du
[Musique]
soleil et tout cela fera un très joli
printemps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parisien